But why do we?
concern ourselves with the integration
because what you're looking at right now on the screen is this is
the normal distribution. It looks something like this.
This is the classical build curve. It's a very
important.
Probability distribution. In fact we can
argue that it's the most
important over distribution
I'll give you examples why it's important and we'll
also look at the formula for the normal
distribution. It's one of the most important formulas
in all of mathematics up
there with E equals MC squared and
you know Newton's laws of physics. It's
so important and that's why it will
be the main focus of today's.
Workshop
But as you can see the normal distribution.
When plotted on a
graph looks just like that graph. I showed
you earlier.
When we were looking at the integration slide.
So what we want to do, for example with the discrete probability
distribution, it was much easier to calculate.
the area now we didn't
look at the
area of a discrete probability distribution
But it's not curved.
It's not curve.
I'll show you a quick. I'll show you a picture very quickly.
Just the
this is from week. This is from what some website but here it
is.
If you look at this graph.
This is a discrete probability distribution. Just a simple rectangular
ships much easier to measure.
the area when you know
They're none when they're not curved.
Okay, but because the normal probability
distribution is continuous which makes it curved.
Or we use integration which will give us this ability to
measure its area.
And that's that's that was my point with talking podcasts.
So if you figure if you ever wonder why is it
that would with with discrete random variables? We
don't talk about calculus, but then when we talk about continuous roundabouts we
have to do calculus well.
It's because of the shape of continuous probability
distributions so very much. It's
a mouthful when I have to say continuous probably
distribution, but I have to because
We do have.
two types of random variables
and each random and both random variables have
their own probability distribution